assise assise
assise ça suffit hein d'accord
coup
bon
fumer is pour des chien anglais hein
il faut une cigarettes anglaises un
chien
anglais j'ai connu un homme qui avait
arrêté de fumer son le chien ne le
reconnaissait plus c'est tout ce qu'il a
gagné arrêter de
fumer il par plus quoi tu conis plus
son allez chante chante chante
ch pareil F
pareil pas ve
pas
[Musique]
nouille reste
là reste
là pas
bouger tu es
con debout debout
debout
oh
gen
gentil gentil tu es bê tu es
bê
tu comme
moi Belle et la
Bête b b non est belle chien chien ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'elle est moche qu' est
qu'elle est gentille et
qu' en fait elle a desos
épouventable et quand quand ce chien
mort il faut découper au ciseau il lâche
pas mais mais pas elle il y en a on m'a
déconseillé les Bou c'est
bourier on m'a déconseillé en disant que
j'aurais des en pouvant sa à la gorge
des autres chiens mais j'ai pris le
risque et
celle-ci
ê à cause de moi elle est elle est elle
est douce quand
même comment mais al il y a un phénomène
intéressant c'est le racisme des
Français envers les les chiens on peut
parler de
racismeac quand on va en Angleterre
c'est un chien anglais les les les
Anglais trouvent ce chien admirable
quand on passe le
Chanel il se fait insulter on dit c'est
un cochon c'est un veau c'est un M c'est
un c'est un
porort parce qu'ils n'ont pashitude les
Français aiment les les caniches les les
Berg
allemands ça ils sont
traumatisés mais comment comment vous
est venue l'idée de prendre cette bête
j'ai c'est un vieux rêve il y a 20 ans
j'avais vu un un homme une trentaine
d'années qui est venu avec un chien
comme ça dans un restaurant et j'ai cru
voir une tapisserie
moyenageuse un chien on voit dans
l'ancien tableau je me suis dit quand
j'aurais un
jardin
j'achèterai j'aurai ce chien
et
Jane l' su et me l'a donné tout
petit à Londres
peut plus retourner en Angleterre
puisque la quarantaine pour les
chiens mais une fois je l'ai perdu en
Espagne alors heureusement il avait
qu'un en Espagne ici il y en a une
quinzaine en France il avait qu'un en
Espagne et on l'a retrouvé grâce à une
émission de télévision je suis venu
montrer des photos mais
j'étais
atrossement absolument fascinant par que
ceux qui ont ces chiens là jamais change
de
race combien de temps vous a pour
trouver et bien j'ai cherché j'ai j'ai
la police m'a aidé les taxis m'ont aidé
elle est sortie de l'hôtel parce qu'une
femme de chambre avait faisait le ménage
pendant qu'on était pas moi j'ai me suis
dit je vais pas laisser dans la salle
enfermé la salle de bain elle sera pas
bien je vais la mettre sur mon lit et
elle s'est sauvée parce que un chien
dans un hôtel c'est c'est pas
et bon il s'est passé 8 jours sans
nouvell je suis rentré en France on m'a
dit votre seule chance c'est de faire
une émission très importante plus
importante émission de
télévision un talk
showémission interview
et le réalisateur espagnol ét très
gentil m'a dit écoutez on va parler ni
de J ni de vous on va parler que du
chien et le lendemain je
retroué l'or couverte de que elle a même
elle a encore des cicatrices elle étit
très malade en France mais c'était
c'était un miracle d'AV les les les
Espagnols m'ont dit vous savez quand un
chien plaît c'est pas c'est pas l'argent
parce j' doné une forte récompense c'est
pas l'argent qui intéressera vous le
retrouverez jamais ce
chien mais je crois que j'ai jamais été
aussi malheureux depuis je pas la mort
de mon père quand j'ai perdu ce chien je
parce moi je je l'ambuscule ça je pas
ses oreilles comme ça par exemple pour
qu'ce un peu
alors je je pas je donne des coups de
pied la traite mal mais quand elle était
pas là c'est l'oxygène mqu c'est
comm nana
ouis elle est là t'inquiétez pas c'est
pour
toi
[Musique]
Bour c'est
bon mauvais pour la
santéf qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre à
Paris à part ça les
bonbonsin la Pte la Pte la
Pte
merci très
bien bah oui ce chien a tourné dans mon
film parce que j'ai trouvé que il a une
dimension poétique qui allit très bien
avec le le
sujet ça paraît paradoxal c'est un bonne
acteur une bonne actrice femelle elle a
regardé qu'une fois la
caméra
pasabo pasabo non elle avait une pâée
production nourrie par un producteur
vous avez les gens qui te promènent leur
chien je dis que c'est pas le chien qui
est au bout de la laiss c'est le
[Musique]
maître